oh my god it's a wiimote what could you
do what we most you could wave it around
what could you do what we most you could
put it on your head yes you could what
could you do what we most you could
insert things into it what could you do
what we most you could use it for
protection
what did you do what we most you could
pull out of it
what could you do move away most you
could use it as a food what could you do
what we moved you could use it to steal
Tyler Oakley's video ideas oh my god
that's such a good video idea I'm
totally gonna steal it we use a Wii
Remote instead what could you do we move
the many things you can do what we built
what could you do what we vote